jeudi soir dernier afida turner était
invité de notre émission pour nous
parler de la disparition de pape diouf
dont elle était visiblement proche
une séquence suite à laquelle la star de
téléréalité a donné son avis sur la
crise mondiale et au corona virus et
sont habillées simple c'est un complot
c'est un coup d'état on est en guerre
sauf que voilà si certains ont réagi sur
le fond de ses déclarations d'autres se
sont attardés sur la forme
de nombreux internautes ont en effet été
choqués par la tenue pour le moins
estivales d'afida qui rappelons le vit
désormais à miami déjà toro parle de toi
donc c'est vrai qu'on disait juste voilà
qui est pas une tenue qui a affolé les
réseaux sociaux et réactions pour le
moins surprenante quand on connaît afida
et son talent légendaire pour innover
toujours plus en terme de tenue choc et
vous comprenez vous les réactions
suscitées par la tenue d'afida turner
alors on va voir la tenue d'afida
regarder puisque c'est face à mathieu
qu'on va faire ce quatrième débat afida
turner face à matthieu delormeau
regardez il ya eu énormément de
critiques autour de la tenue d'afida
voilà pascal fidal dit ce qu'elle veut
voilà mais elle savait aussi comme elle
veut mine de rien à regarder
on va voir la tenue d'afida regarder la
tenue est juste après afida ça sera face
à mathieu ces partis regarder à te met
juste en garde parce que tu es très
populaire tu as une voix qui porte
regardes tu viens de parler étaient des
gens top tweets en moins de dix minutes
déjà tantôt depuis déjà trop de parle de
toi donc c'est vrai qu'on me disait
juste que voilà t'es pas c'est pas
anodin quand tu dis quelque chose
voilà merci oui oui jean michel alors
voilà donc afida qui a fait non on parle
et afida qui est avec nous m'ont soir
afida alors à bonsoir merci
très belle tenue merci afida afida as
alors mathieu est infidèle vous allez
être opposé à fida qui est bien sûr
chanteuse et producteur à leur rythme
sans merci afida à blida est heureux la
question se dépasser pour est vrai pas
si on peut mieux commencer pour
remercier en fait tous les hôpitaux les
aides soignants qui sauvent des vies
aujourd'hui quand nous on se la coulent
douce et on s'amuse bon ça c'est la
première chose j'aimerais finalement
pouvoir parler correctement sans être
coupés puisque la dernière fois je
n'avais pas de feedback et pas de retour
pour présenter mes condoléances à tous
les proches à la famille de pat lufa son
fils antoine et à sa fille tu as bien
fait de mettre le peuple français
voilà bah tu as bien raison un fils
damian pense très fort la famille de
pape diouf également voilà et manu
dibango aussi à la famille de manu
dibango qui était un immense artiste
douce un gars un mec exceptionnel afida
voile attention donc ta tenue a beaucoup
fait parler
c'est vrai notamment matthieu delormeau
tu vas être en face de lui dans sept
quarts de finale de la coupe du monde
des débats afida déjà qu'est ce que tu
as à dire aux gens qu'ils étaient
choqués par tâtonnement mais je dirais
avant tout que je suis là pour divertir
les gens c'est vrai qu'à des gens
d'aujourd'hui qui sont tous dans les
hôpitaux et qui n'ont pas la chance
comme nous de pouvoir faire des
émissions ou pouvoir regarder de
divertissement et donc j'avais envie
finalement d'égayer ce peuple français
qui est malheureusement au jour
d'aujourd'hui dans une guerre et dans
longtemps dans une situation très
délicate et je pense qu'il va encore se
marrer comme à l'époque de coluche comme
à l'époque de canal+ avec avec à
dominique et tous ces gens et farrugia
voilà on fait du divertissement on n'est
pas dans une mission de de paris
première dans les bd cruellement un
accès moins contenir donc évidemment on
est dans une émission devait se tenir un
moment donné faut dire la vérité alors
critiqué c'est très simple mais moi à la
base n'avait pas de retour j'avais envie
de faire un hommage à mon ami pape diouf
et à sa famille à son fils antoine et sa
fille et ses proches
voilà et surtout un très grand merci à
tous ces gens dans les hôpitaux qui
sauvent des vies en chair ça c'est le
plus important je ne suis pas en france
mais mon coeur y est thomas wheeler
j'espère que tout le monde pourra
entendre et à peux dire à ce moi tout
seul à miami how do happen
afida afida juste afida kiki sacchi
s'applaudit mathieu toi alors t'aime
beaucoup afida je le sais tu me l'a dit
vous verrez qu il aime beaucoup et a été
choquée donc elle toit par certains sa
tenue absolument parce que l'année alors
elle a fait énormément parler sur les
réseaux en date du date afida la voix ça
c'est si vrai que c'est vrai qu'on les
aime beaucoup afida que ce soit toi au
moins on aime beaucoup alors dis nous ce
que tu en penses quoi
oui parce que j'aime beaucoup quand elle
me fait rire et côté bien pour me faire
rire et se trouve que quand tu comptes
tu vas passer un entretien d'embauché
tu mets une jolie tenue tu mets une
cravate c'est une manière de respecter
la personne que tu as en face la cantine
a parlé du cornet virus alors qu'on va
atteindre 70 mille morts dans le monde
et qui a des gens qui sont dans des
hôpitaux en détresse respiratoire et et
les gens qui nous regardent
regardez qui ont aujourd'hui des amis ou
de la famille dans les hôpitaux mathieu
non mais je te coupe 12,2 secondes là
mathieu là c'est vrai que moi j'ai
montré aussi tout à l'heure et vidéos
drôles du coronavirus bien sûr c'est un
moment très très grave c'est un moment
très important mais là elle a dit un
truc afida on est dans une émission une
dernière de divertissement elle n'était
pas là pour parler ligne de rien des cas
graves de corps en un virus non parce
que si tu commences à dire ça nous aussi
on va nous dire qu'on peut rigoler sur
des trucs et c'est donc à fidel a dit on
est dans une émission de divertissement
là je sois d'accord avec ton résonance
il si on voudrait nous libèrera zir six
venus nous divertir dans ces cas là
cyril fallait qu'elle nous fasse rire là
elle est venue à les venues pour nous
exposer une origine et de goudron
d'artisans que le chine où les chinois
et les américains c'est pas un avis à un
complot et je te rappelle d'ailleurs
cyril que je suis devant son twitter
elle a retweeté jean marie le pen
donc si tu veux pour moi n'est pas venu
pour nous divertir elle est venue pour
donner un avis un avis politique qui à
mon sens d'abord est dangereux et tu
viens pas d'abord soutenir une théorie
du complot avec une coupe de champagne
et à maillot de bain avec des idées qui
sont sortis de ton décolleté avec un
mode baky 30 dans la raie des fesses
pour pour construire des ponts des
théories pareil ça n'a aucun sens
une bugatti sont battus olite mathieu
deux minutes je vais défendre afida de
2nde nature on était les premiers à et
en fous rires donc s'il vous plaît
écoutez entier comme un trou du cul à la
ville est comme un trou du cul tout
moment là en revanche là vous avez un
énorme avec un énorme trou du cul vous
travaillez pas au point et vous ne
travaillez pas aussi les rêves et n'y
allez à là c'est pas sûr de lui ok de
lanvaux moi je vous adore on a fait des
parties ont maintenu qu'en bord de la
mer
jamais reçu un chèque ce soir et en
images s'il vous plaît à comment là il
faut changer de métier avait travaillé à
l'institut pasteur fait des vaccins
allaient travailler pour house façon à
vous trouverez peut-être peut-être vous
pourriez peut-être donner un avis un
avis parce que j'étais en body parce que
les temps avaient un barbecue je me fais
tellement chez genou et moi enfin que
moi je nourris les gens qui n'ont pas
vous fais ok donc je fais un barbecue
j'étais en body et ensuite je vais
servir des repas et vous fait quoi de
l'ormeau parce qu'un avis c'est quand
même un trou du cul tout le monde à ses
parents sont les confiner je dois être
confiées ok donc afida à gratin fida a
fait dame g2play un acide abbott
quand on a un avis comme tu dis mais que
son avis est un avis extrêmement
dangereux quant aux tenues de jean marie
le pen et qu'on a à la théorie du
complot c'est pas un avis qu'il faut
avoir dans ces cas-là ce qu'il faut
avoir c'est des preuves parce que c'est
très dangereux sur les autres ont créé
du racing a laissé parler mathieu a
laissé femme et mathieu mathieu chéri
pas les cinquantenaires ma chérie moi je
pense que tu es venu avec ton maillot de
bain en sortant des théories aberrante
et complotistes uniquement pour pouvoir
derrière faire ce que tu as fait c'est à
dire marquer sur instagram que afida
turner faisait le buzz de parler mathieu
pour avoir de la visibilité qu'on te
voit et qu'on parle de toi car tu ne vis
que de ça du buzz et de ton image mais
faire du buzz et de ton image avec un
maillot de bain sur un sujet comme le
corona c'est une honte à sida honte à
toi
alors on a ce soir vous avez un avis ok
vous allez laisser parler voilà jean
marie le pen c'est très important a dit
une chose un maire qui est très belle
les chinois sont les plus gros seins du
standard était innovant oui oui mais un
fidèle à vous pouvez pas traiter jean
marie le pen pouvait pas dire n'importe
quoi
la season
c'est évident mais vous pouvez passer
déjà avancé le pen vous dites n'importe
quoi la finale on est dans le
divertissement la la c'est vous qui
sortez du divertissement la tuna suis
désolé si abassi je suis désolé non mais
là vous dites n'importe quoi là on part
on parle madame et afida hafid al fida
on parle de votre tenue
on parle de votre tenue on n'est pas sur
des terrains avec les polices qui sont
n'importe quoi et qui font peur aux gens
et qui sont dangereuses afida donc là je
suis pas d'accord vous êtes venus pour
parler de votre body de votre tenue qui
a choqué les gens sur les réseaux
sociaux
on n'est pas là pour parler des théories
de jean marie le pen il était henri
d'extrême droite qui sur n'importe quoi
mais je le dis c'est n'importe quoi
mais tous se parler ou pas où je vais
être coupée comme ça oui mais oui mais
est juste resté sur le rester sur le
sujet afida je ne veux pas qu'on soit
dans les côtes et opposition s'étaient
au logement apparaît de l'open c'est de
la remorque à paris le pen avec les
chinois effectivement les chinois sont
dit oui mais là on n'a pas le temps
merci donc ma tenue est très bien ma
tenue était pour divertir c'est une île
une émission divertissement et les gens
qui sont dans les hôpitaux moment d en
fait d'apparaître dans une tenue un peu
d'eau si quand on est permis à mu mais
sinon aussi de leurs mollets tellement
mal ou ne pas porter la maison je pense
pas que ça passe au maire résultat je
suis pas jaloux et final je trouve juste
que tu vaux plus que ça et que mes
n'existait que dans la vulgarité
je trouve que c'est pas très très bien
arriver le geek on coupe de champagne et
un maillot de bain de borat à la
télévision et voilà dans ces cas là vie
raconté une blague a raconté une blague
dans ces cas là si tout nous divertir
chauny et on est de fou mais c'est pas
parce qu'on est confiné qu'on revient
des confréries hockey en body moi
j'espère les gens tournent pas bouffer
faut tu fais quoi tu te critike capitale
on a envie d'y aller ou non j'ai 18
attendu j'aimerais j'aimerais que ça se
termine bien tous les deux parce qu'on
vous aimez tous les deux beaucoup je dis
juste afida que le problème c'est qu'on
ne peut pas vivre que du buzz du buzz de
genre de buzz là tu es venu l'émission
c'est très bien
tu nous as diverti on a beaucoup ri mais
effectivement tu n'est venu que dans un
but c'était convoite en maillot de bain
on parle de toi que tu existes sur les
réseaux sociaux étaient pas du tout venu
dans un autre but que tu hamilton ''sans
charitables ça j'y crois pas mon chéri
tu y crois pas été aidés voilà je peux
faire en football
parce que ton aliment pour voir son chef
de notre mieux demain 15000 euros
oui il faut bien aider les gens j'ai pas
entendu il faut bien aider les gens oui
je veux que wayne on s'était pas magasin
c'était un beau 10 c'est le happy days
tenant boutique je vends en fait pour
pouvoir d'accord récolter des fonds pour
pouvoir aider pour pouvoir faire un don
tout simplement
voilà le seul problème c'est que moi et
de leur monde est super x paraissait
prix cour il s'est pris pour le
rédacteur en chef du point
le rédacteur en chef du cnrs ou le
directeur général de l'institut pasteur
à lille mais écoute de leurs mots ont
fait du divertissement au kef à la love
you no 19 sec et je ne vois plus une
goutte d'alcool tu vois pas comment tu
mens je suis enchanté mais je vais chez
les chimistes yoplait mathieu et afida
dites-vous aux petits trucs gentils tous
les deux parce que je sais que vous
aimez beaucoup c'est que je l'adoré qu
on a rigolé venu au bureau
j'adore la fida qui me divertit j'aime
moins la fida qui est en maillot de bain
pour venir dire des bêtises c'est tout
bon bah c'est bon tu vas pas le relier à
voir partir au capital tepa mans n'était
pas mon mari je vend à prix d'or est pas
les masses pas les masses ce soir je
voudrais pas un grand remerciement à
tous les gens dans le soap ito qui se
battent ils sauvent des vies
ça c'est plus important qaïda qui est en
bikini cheryl ann là et qui fera à dont
je vens rieudebat 15000 dollars
ceci dit après ça en guise de conclusion
de leur mort pourrait l'ouvrir
même si je vous adore et on fera un
barbecue est pas d'accord pour moi jean
paul ninard les fêtes elle veut vendre
son maillot aux enchères si loin
donner c'est paradoxalement son annonce
et quand on donne de l'argent bon là pas
de la fille d'un étudiant de leur faut
être aussi jaloux c'est pour les gens
qui n'ont rien à bouffer ici on s'est
appuyé les gens à l'aller c'est bon s'il
vous plaît afida s'il te plaît ma chérie
en tout cas reste comme tu es dans le
divertissement de là aussi je peux
donner un conseil et arrête de citer les
théories d'extrême droite ne citer jean
marie le pen faut arrêter le site et
voir tout ça d'accord très bien allez on
va voir ce concours si les
téléspectateurs
je suis très claire dans mais on va voir
ce qu'on pense étaient les spectateurs
voilà ce qu'on peut abbas et mathieu qui
vous a le plus convaincu à 80% mathieu
don qui sera rang en 2009 afida
franchement voilà et est ce que vous
comprenez on pourra voir deuxième de
deuxième sondage souplesse que vous
comprenez les réactions suscitées par la
tenue de danseuse voilà dans ce soir
chez ba ba oui à 75% non à 25 ans
afida en tout cas merci d'avoir été là
et mathieu et afida faites vous un petit
bijou quand même parce que j'aime pas
que que je vous soyez comme ça voilà
voilà en chiffonnade j'aime pas ça mais
j'aime ton excentricités afida et jeu et
je t'aime tu aurais tu me fais rire
voilà je t'aime fort après voilà je
n'aime pas la finale
c'est une fleur pour toi pourquoi la
peur pour toi toujours toujours très
très très très positive merci merci la
france pour tous les mandats tu crois
quoi on n'est rien merci à fait d'or qui
vit dans les hôpitaux
c'est ça le plus important